yes hi it's carlos ferreira i am the
founder and CEO why ski we are a global
growth company member of the World
Economic Forum in relation to what is
reviews about how ceos act differently
from the other type of executives around
the world and what concerns major
projects and problems i will say that
one of the differences here in the World
Economic Forum is the productivity CEOs
have in order to become solution to
major problems in a very proactive and
efficient way one of the difference we
could say between g20 order big meetings
is that they speak more than what they
act here is action is more the key
essentials is actually oriented and
trying to solve problems how we saw
problems by first of all identify them
and being able to understand the
consequences of those problem
interrelate a man or self-organized
sessions debating bringing or individual
experiences and approaches and at the
end of the day find compromises on
solutions I guess what is happening here
for instantly relations between one of
the question is how China and India can
deal together in ink were concerns of
things that divide them and how they can
overcome those divisions I would say the
new generation of chinese and indian
entrepreneurs that have been also
assistant to the Dalian world economic
forum that they are more proactive to
find solution and to try to become
really friendly in what concerns the
future evolution in the world needs now
corporation those are the two major
pillars on the world economy now India
and China so they have to show
leadership and they have to show that
they are really willing to show the rest
of the world how to play together I
think I confrontational China and India
in terms of business or internal
Environmental Protection will only heart
the rest of the world so we need
leadership in this region of the world I
think Indians are extraordinarily well
positioned to provide to show that
leadership the Chinese are actually as
well as many of the things to divide
them they are becoming
less and less relevant especially for
the new generation and we believe that
is a huge hope for the future